looking to Asia now China unveiled plans
to revive its economy the world's second
largest after those strict covid
restrictions they lasted for years while
President Xi Jinping is using the annual
Gathering of China's national Parliament
to tighten his control on the country
overall Elizabeth Palmer now shows us
how the new policies might affect us
here in the U.S amid strained relations
between the two countries
[Music]
National people's Congress the largest
rubber stamp parliament in the world has
convened in Beijing
this week almost 3 000 delegates will
enshrine in-law the wishes of their
leader China's president Xi Jinping
she's zero coveted policy with his
ruthless quarantines and epic testing
did huge economic damage to China at the
Congress Premier League kochang made it
clear repairing the damage is a top
priority
the development Target he said is growth
of around five percent but it's not
clear that growth will translate into
good news for American businesses in
China so there's a chill in the air
there certainly is a chill in the air as
U.S China relations sour some American
companies fear they're already Suffering
The Fallout Michael Hart heads the
American Chamber of Commerce in Beijing
companies feel like they're squeezed out
of certain industries and so there is a
question mark that many U.S companies
have about you know are we really
welcome that depends to a large extent
on President XI he officially begins an
unprecedented third term later this week
backed by an inner circle chosen above
all for their loyalty they will support
him whether he seeks to escalate
confrontation with the U.S and its
allies or dial it back all eyes will be
on the Congress this week for Clues as
to which way that might go for CBS
mornings Elizabeth Palmer Tokyo